so i never actually said this before but
i
just hopped off a plane at lax
jenna
she ran out of plane so we have to go
home and pack we just came from san
francisco and then we're gonna drive
to anaheim tonight come on okay let's go
it's gonna be really fun it's actually
not gonna be any fun at all because
tomorrow is the first day of vidcon
we're probably not gonna get to anaheim
until at least 2 a.m so
we'll see what happens
this place is a complete disaster
honestly if it catches fire we're all
dead because we can't get out
almost packed sort of sort of sort of
sort of not at all what time is it
it's late it's probably midnight oh
we're never gonna get there
somehow we made it i have no idea how we
made it here to be honest with you
because i drove he drove i edited i was
writing out the plan of explaining what
i'm doing for this weekend
i
actually you have arrived we've arrived
we've already anxiety is through the
roof it's really high oh my god i'm so
nervous okay it's day one of vidcon in
my bag i've got my actual shoes and
yerbas i can't believe that we drove up
here last night i don't remember i drove
it was actually this morning because we
got in around one okay we gotta go cause
we're late honestly like i'm trying
we're like
we're so
pretty so we finally made it over here
we got some nice escorts here today
so we're heading to a panel now and i
think
i think that's what we're doing look how
cool this looks oh my gosh
it's all my friends all my friends are
on the wall
look at this
all of our friends
up here
oh my gosh look at you
oh right
you're gonna like i'm gonna sell you
yourself or not
yeah you got to do the same face though
whoa it's like a little too excited
a little bit like
the new xbox one was revealed this past
week i was there
if that's something that you'd be
interested in thumbs up or leave me a
comment
winking is so stupid
icon of the tech scene of the gaming
scene and she's really one of the most
creative and largest forces in pop
culture today she got over three million
subscribers or subs as we like to call
them and she's got nearly half a billion
with a b
video views give it up for i just feet
i don't even know what i filmed today
it's been so overwhelming because you
get to one place and there's so many
people running around we're about to go
and film a little clip for youtube
nation so i'm pretty excited here's
jacob jacob is he's
pretty much the most amazing host i've
ever seen
today
it's day two
here we go this is actually officially
day one because the first day was
industry day so
it just counts as day one yeah
okay so we're here this is the second
day of vidcon i don't even know what i
filmed yesterday but i'm really excited
because i'm here at the shapeways well i
guess this is the booth we're in a room
i don't know what's going on because
vidcon is so crazy there's like people
everywhere but i'm about to get a 3d
scan of my body and
then it'll be 3d printed into myself me
too wow
so cute
so we're about to head into the
exhibition hall which is kind of crazy
because everybody is down there uh and
right now we're taking the freight
elevator down to get there no passengers
no passengers
except today except today we just had a
meeting with canon
they're so nice you guys know like i've
been telling you like it's my dream like
i just want to tell them like
how to make a perfect camera which i
don't think i did a very good job
because i was so excited sitting in this
room so i will have to write down my
ideas but they gave us a new camera and
i'm so excited because if you guys
remember when i was cooking cupcakes
with joey uh
my old the canon vixia
might
not work because of the cupcake that was
smashed into the lens so we got one of
the new versions and jenna got one too
gave me one too because i was telling
them how i had a lens there in my one
and they were like oh we felt bad here
you go there's a thank you so much okay
here we go
it's okay
we can figure it out at least we're down
here though
we just ended up with a volleyball game
oh my god
thank you
oh my god i miss volleyball so much
hey youtube hello follow me on twitter
love your work
so right now i'm doing a live demo here
oh okay so you can see it
this right there
so you can film the front and the back
completely necessary
but completely really cool
so now i'm filming my reaction hey guys
guys we're off to head to a panel it's
called a guide to vlogging panel um i'm
pretty excited are you good hi hi hi
just found out you guys are on the piano
putting my serious panel face on
that's my serious face what's it called
a guide to vlogging we're so ready to
guide people yeah
you know i think we basically wrote the
guide uh it's a pdf you can download it
on guidetoblogging.com i bet that's
already taken i'm sure it is if not we
should take it we should take it
definitely
yeah
i think it'll be okay this is really
hard vlogging with you guys because i
have to go down here and then i'm like
hey hi yeah sorry about that very
convenient
well i'm very excited i think this will
be a fun panel so hopefully everyone
will enjoy it you guys probably won't
see it
i don't is this stuff like livestream i
don't think it's livestream i don't like
to either so everything we say it was
really great it was a success and
everyone loved it that's how it went and
we're gonna fight to the death so you
probably won't see any of us ever again
true that's true bye we had fun i hope
somebody edits this really nice for me
we're vlogging we're on a panel
i think phil was supposed to be here i
don't know
oh hey day three vidcon i am
so sick like yesterday i got so sick on
the panel i was like i'm getting a fever
i don't think i'm gonna even be able to
make it through this and then i had to
go do another panel after that i'm sorry
i told you it's not good no it's so bad
um but i'm about to open up this new
camera that i'm gonna use today yeah so
i'm pretty excited
whoa productive cough i'm sorry we're
both ill
i have to skip
and open my coasting that i'm doing
because i don't think i can do it i
would much rather do my meet up
and i'm sad if anybody was going there
to see me do whatever it was that i was
doing but i don't think i'm gonna be
able to make it oh my god this is like
the most exhausting event ever but it's
so awesome getting to see all of you
guys so uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna open up my little camera and
go to a meeting and get ready and go see
you guys meet up here it is i'm gonna
test it out so the next video will be
with the vixia minnie
oh hi hello testing out the zoom is this
too close is this too far is this too
close is this too far how's the focus i
don't know all right jen we're heading
over
oh it's blurry no focus focus focus oh
here's have a drink
you're focused nope
see look
oh well
there you go fixed it oh hi
so
okay here we go guys this is it this is
it
go ahead okay
oh my goodness oh my goodness okay i'm
really excited we've got our first
iphone
did you sign it oh no okay are you sure
yeah sure all right
shout out to your sidebar
he just came up here i recognized him
from our panel yesterday and jenna was
like oh so you have an interest in
working and so you want to work for us
should we all twerk
okay we're gonna i'm not
thank you
oh
all right so vidcon is over i'm so tired
i'm not feeling well um and there's been
some riots because you're not allowed
into the hilton without a rookie and
this guy didn't have a room
and he tried to he tried to sneak in
what a liar
he's like um 1104 like that's not a room
number but it's not it's not so we
should have been home by now but uh
apparently the hilton may or may not
have left my car on for like six days
straight so now i don't have a battery
in my car and triple a is on its way so
we're now going to the lego store come
come look at this here
see see what they're do they're doing
this is this is where i got my
inspiration oh okay
shadow doesn't care they're using half
brick look at you
it's you
gotta be able to oh my gosh
look at the big legos it's everything
what am i gonna oh sorry
what am i gonna get jen
you're gonna get something
that's a lot of work and trust me i know
when you had your structure and i he
backed into it and i broke his arm off
yeah i do i was traumatized and i tried
to fix it i couldn't i do remember
good morning we're uh we're about to
leave anaheim for the second time third
time actually to try to leave
and hopefully they're able to fix my car
this time like i'm beyond
exhausted i still feel
terrible we're gonna try to go to
starbucks we haven't been able to go all
week because the line has been so long
and the dentists are here also there's
dentist convention and oh it's also it's
kind of unfortunate that
like our fellow youtubers are pigs um
like the hilton is not going to want to
have us back because this place is
destroyed like the outside hall there's
like someone sprayed something all over
the walls there's like sugar packets
yesterday there was like food everywhere
red like it just bread like broken into
pieces like thrown against the walls you
can tell it was disgusting yeah so if
you guys come to a place like this uh be
respectful because it's kind of
disgusting and they're not gonna want to
have us back and that makes everybody
look bad i apologize to the manager
yesterday for on all of our behalfs yup
pigs i i think we should take all the
stuff check it at valet
yeah make them deal with it they broke
your car
just kidding no they might have because
if they couldn't lock my car so you
couldn't lock my car the bat the
heads-up display stays on unless you
open the door and shut it
so it's okay things happen but we got
really delicious pizza out of the deal
and i got a lego set
this is try number three triple a thank
you i guess that's what those three a's
mean i was gonna say
three a's mean third time's a charm
you